and finally new rule Catholic
conservatives who don't like the Pope
have to stop lying about his record
number Bob Dole stop lying about my
record they talk about the Pope like
he's gone rogue he's off the reservation
inventing his own brand of socialist
Christianity no he's just quoting Jesus
sell everything you own and give it to
the poor be on your guard against all
kinds of greed when you give a banquet
invite the poor even though they cannot
repay you and of course here have a fish
I made enough for everyone that's not a
real because let's face it Republicans
this is not really the face that best
reflects your party's values this is
yes by now most of you have probably
heard the story of Martin shkreli the 32
year old financial wonder [ __ ] and
massive and massing Gil spokesman who
bought the rights to a life-saving drug
called daraprim which is used by AIDS
sufferers cancer patients and infants
and then jacked up the price of a single
pill from 1350 to 750 dollars even
Ticketmaster was like oh come
I'd say how do you sleep but I guess you
just hang upside down in your cave and
now that surely is not that shkreli is
unusual for the pharmaceutical industry
15 years ago cancer drugs cost an
average of ten thousand dollars a year
now it's ten thousand dollars a month
because this cartel owns the US
government every bit as much as Mexican
drug lords own theirs
and to all the Conservatives who still
parrot the line that Obamacare is a
government takeover please don't explain
why guys like Martin shkreli are still
calling the shots he's not a bureaucrat
it works for the government he's a hedge
fund manager who works for the devil and
here's his rationale if there's a
company that was selling an aston martin
at the price of a bicycle and we buy
that company and we check we asked to
charge toyota prices i don't think that
should be a crime you accept that owning
an aston martin is not a matter of life
and death
i mean
at least until it's bought by Volkswagen
and the fact that this story played out
last week during a papal visit exposed
just how little these so-called
Christians of the far right believe in
what Jesus actually said how could they
there is not a tent in the world big
enough to fit under it both Jesus and
Ayn Rand in order to be both Republican
and Christian they had to create an
entirely new Jesus we'd only have two
Americas we have two Jesus's now it's
true liberals have the traditional Jesus
who hated rich [ __ ] and wouldn't
shut up about how they should give away
all their money and conservatives made
up a completely new Jesus a small
business man from Galilee whose main
gripe is big government who wants to
make Nazareth great again
I call him supply-side Jesus he'd love
to help the less fortunate but he's got
an investor to think about like the time
supply-side Jesus performed a miracle
and created a bounty of loaves and
fishes and then gave them all to the top
1% so they could trickle down to the
takers
or the time supply spike Jesus came upon
a leper who has to be healed
so supply side Jesus bought the company
that makes leprosy medication and jacked
up the price Jesus may have said it's
easier for a camel to pass through the
eye of a needle than for a rich man to
enter heaven but it was supply side
Jesus who said to ever tell you about
the time I shot a camel in conclusion I
would just like to say that Donald Trump
is actually the perfect candidate for
today's Republicans because he says he
does that his two favorite books are the
Bible and the art of the deal Trump says
one is about a perfect God who teaches
you man humanity the right way to live
and the other is the Bible
you